cette très jeune fille qui hurle sa
douleur et son amour au passage du
convoi funèbre de claude françois
peut-être avait-elle passé une partie de
la nuit comme beaucoup d'autres aux
abords de l'église de paye
sous la pluie pendant des heures les
fans montagne où certains jusqu'à
l'épuisement
les fleurs des couronnes nombreuses le
président de la république avait délégué
monsieur philippe choses et son chef de
cabinet pour assister à la cérémonie
l'autre choix très bon soit il y a pas
d'homme discret
d
mais
et
l'unique chants religieux de la
cérémonie l'avé maria de gounod fut
interprétée par les fléchettes très ému
le premier groupe qui accompagne à
claude françois dans ces enregistrements
les
la dépouille de claude françois devait
être ensuite conduite au cimetière de
dannemois un petit village de l'essonne
où la vedette vivait avec sa mère depuis
quelques années dans une propriété
baptisée le moulin
seuls les intimes furent admis à la mise
en terre on reconnaît ici madame
françoise ceux tenus par paul lederman
le premier imprésario de claude françois
gbagbo
beaucoup
oui
ap